today we are talking about code samples
security
and a different kind of chatbot i am
priyanka and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
for the first time ever cloud.google.com
code samples can be
searched for a single location so far
the search page includes
8 600 code samples across 7
programming languages with language
product
and keyword filters available check out
the blog post to learn more or head over
to cloud.google.com
docs samples
join us for our first google cloud
security talks of 2021
a live online event on march 3rd where
we will help you navigate the latest in
cloud security
reserve your virtual seat now to hear
experts discuss
topics like risk management information
governance
in google workspace machine learning to
better protect
networks the future of confidential
computing
and more getting the job you want
requires you to stand out to potential
employers
especially in the current job market
recently one of our customer engineers
did just that
by building a conversational chat bot on
google cloud that answers questions
about professional experience
plus some surprises check out a new way
to stand out and learn more
on the blog if you want to stop those
clever phishing attacks
use security keys a security key is a
physical device that works alongside
your username and password
to verify your identity to a site or an
app
they produce stronger login protection
than an authenticator app
or sms code and the same device can be
used for many services
so you don't need to carry around a
necklace of dongles or fobs
in this issue of gcp comics we are
covering exactly that
check it out for more if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet
us we'll see you in the cloud